[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من الرياض نقدم
من خلالها ابرز اخبار وملفات السعوديه
والخليج الى ابرز العناوين
تزامنا مع زياره الرئيس الصيني الى روسيا
الاتحاد الاوروبي يوافق على شراء ذخيره
لاوكرانيا بمليار يورو
في الكويت اعلان حاله الطوارئ بسبب التسرب
النفطي غرب البلاد دون ان يتسبب باصابات
او غازات سامه
منذ بدئه عام 2019 موسم الترفيه في
السعوديه يستقبل 120 مليون زائر لنحو 9000
فعاليه
وفي ملفاتنا المتنوعه ايضا
قبل تطبيق النظام الجديد وزاره السياحه
السعوديه تهدد المخالفين بغرامه قدرها
مليون ريال او اغلاق منشاتهم
في الرياض العربيه تحتفي بعشرين عاما منذ
تاسيسها وتطلق اذاعه العربيه اف ام
اهلا بكم نبدا باخر تطورات الحرب في
اوكرانيا وبدايه من التسليح الغربي لكياف
حيث اعلن دبلوماسي اوروبي انا دول الاتحاد
وافقت على خطه لشراء ذخيره لاوكرانيا
بقيمه مليار يورو واضاف الدبلوماسي ان
الخطه تتكون من ثلاث مراحل لتزويد القوات
الاوكرانيه بما لا يقل عن مليون قذيفه من
عيار 155 ملم الدعم الاوروبي ياتي تزامنا
مع وصول الرئيس الصيني تشي الى موسكو في
زياره رسميه حيث يلتقي بعد قليل الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين لبحث العديد من
القضايا الثنائيه والعالميه والازمه في
اوكرانيا واكد الرئيس الصيني فور وصوله
الى ان الصين مستعده للعمل المشترك مع
روسيا على حمايه النظام العالمي القائميه
على القانون الدولي وان تطور العلاقات بين
الصين وروسيا يصب في مصلحه العالم باسره
واكدت الرئاسه الروسيه الكرملين ان الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين سيطلع نظيره الصيني
تشيجينج على رؤيه روسيا ووجهه نظرها تجاه
الازمه في اوكرانيا وقال المتحدث باسم
الكريم
ونظيره الصيني سيناقشان خطه السلام
الصينيه لكنه اشار ايضا الى ان الولايات
المتحده لا تريد حتى خفض التصعيد وتواصل
العداء ضد روسيا ولا يتوقع ان تقبل باي
وساطه وبشان مذكره الجنائيه الدوليه
لاعتقال بوتين اكد بيسكوف ان هذه الخطوه
دليل على عداء المحكمه لروسيا ولرئيسها
من جهته قال المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الصينيه
ان زياره الرئيس تشيمبينغ الى روسيا تهدف
الى تعزيز العلاقات بين البلدين مؤكدا
موقف الصين الموضوعي الحد وصفه بشان الحرب
الاوكرانيه الروسيه
زياره الرئيس هي رحله صداقه وتعاون وسلام
وستجري مناقشه الرئيس بوتين حول العلاقات
الثنائيه والقضايا الدوليه والاقليميه
لتعزيز التنسيق الاستراتيجي بين البلدين
وضخ زخم جديد في تنميه العلاقات كما سيطبق
البلدان مبادئ عدم الانحياز وعدم استهداف
الاطراف الثالثه كما سيعززان اطفاء
الطابعه الديمقراطي على العلاقات الدوليه
وبناء نمط عالمي متعدد الاقطاب بجانب
تحسين الحوكمه العالميه الصين ستتمسك
بموقفها الموضوعي والعادل بشان الازمه
الاوكرانيه وستلعب دورا بناء في تعزيز
محادثات السلام
وتزامنا مع زياره الرئيس الصيني دعت وزاره
الخارجيه الاوكرانيه لان يستغل خلال
الزياره نفوذه للضغط على موسكو لوقف
الحربه ونقلت وكاله فرانس براس عن
المتحدثين باسم الخارجيه الاوكرانيه
كثب زياره الرئيس الصيني لروسيا وتتوقع ان
تستخدم بيكيين نفوذها على موسكو لوضع حد
للحرب في اوكرانيا
اعلنت لجنه التحقيق الروسيه عن فتح تحقيق
جنائي مع المدعي العام للمحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه كريم خان بعد ان اصدرت المحكمه
التي تتخذ من لهااي مقرا لها مذكره توقيف
بحق الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين واوضحت لجنه
التحقيق انها فتحت تحقيقا جنائيا ضد
المدعي العام للمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
والقضاه الذين اصدروا مذكره توقيف بحق
بوتين بتهم تتعلق بارتكاب جرائم حرب مؤكده
ان العديد من قضاه المحكمه استندوا الى
قرار غير قانوني بالسعي الاعتقاله
حول التطورات الميدانيه للمعركه اصدرت
وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه بيانا قالت فيه
ان القوات الروسيات تحقق مكاسب في مدينه
افديافكا الواقعه شمال دنيا كما اشار
البيان الى ان الوضع التكتيكي في المدينه
يشبه ما يحدث في بخموت وانها اصبحت مدمره
بالكامل واكدت الدفاع البريطانيه كذلك ان
القوات الاوكرانيه تواصل الدفاع بثبات عن
المدينه
قلا وزير الخارجيه التركي مولود شاويش
اوغلو ان مصر لا ترتاح للوجود التركي في
ليبيا واضاف ان وجود تركيا هناك لا يشكل
خطرا على مصر مشيرا الى انه تم الاتفاق مع
القاهره على مواصله التشاور والتعاون
الوثيق بشان ليبيا وزير خارجيه تركيا قال
كذلك ان الاتفاقيه البحريه المبرمه بين
انقره وحكومه الوحده الوطنيه الليبيه ليست
ضد مصالح مصر مشيرا الى ان مصر راعت مصالح
انقره حينما ابرمت اتفاقا بحريا مع
اليونان
افاد مراسل العربيه ان مؤتمر المانحين
لدعم متضرري الزلزال في تركيا وسوريا يبحث
تقديرات اوليه حول حاجات المناطق المنكوبه
في سوريا وتركيا وكشف دبلوماسيون اوروبي
للعربيه ان غياب العلاقات الدبلوماسيه مع
نظام السوري ادى الى عدم دعوته الى مؤتمر
المانحين وان الخطوط الحمراء تعرقل تقديم
مساعدات الاعمار الى سوريا مؤكدا عدم رؤيه
اي افق لتخفيف العقوبات المفروضه على
النظام السوري
اكد مصدر للعربيه ان وفدا من الحكومه
الشرعيه اليمنيه وميليشيا الحوثي اتفقا في
ختام جولات المفاوضات في جنيف على تبادل
880 اسيرا ومختطفا من الجانبين بينهم وزير
الدفاع الاسبق اللواء محمود صبيحي ولواء
ناصر منصور هادي شقيق الرئيس اليمني
السابق وكل من نجل العميد طارق صالح عضو
مجلس القياده الرئاسي وشقيقه واضاف المصدر
ان بقيه الاسرى المخطوفين المشمولين في
اتفاق ابريل سيتم البحث في تبادل اطلاق
سراحهم في جوله مفاوضات قادمه
اعتقلت الشرطه الباكستانيه نحو 285 من
انصار رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران خان
ومساعديه في مداهمات بمدينتين وفقا ما
ذكره حزب حركه الانصاف والشرطه تاتي حمله
الاعتقالات في اطار حمله تستهدف المتورطين
في اشتباكات اندلعت مؤخرا مع الشرطه
الاسبوع الماضي خلال محاوله اعتقال خان من
منزله قبل ان يشتبكوا لاحقا مع الشرطه في
اسلام اباد لدى وصوله للمثل امام محكمه
يوم السبت
اطلقت شرطه مكافحه الشغب الكنيه الغاز
الموسيلي للدموع ومدافع المياه ضد
المتظاهرين الذين احتجوا على ازمه غلاء
المعيشه في البلاد حيث اندلعت معارك بين
متظاهرين والشرطه في اجزاء من روبي ومدن
اخرى في اول اضطرابات كبيره منذ تولي
الرئيس ويليام روتو الرئاسه العامه الماضي
قال رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي كيفن
مقارتي انه لا يريد احتجاجات او اعمال عنف
اذا تم توجيه لائحه اتهام ضد الرئيس
السابق ترامب مشددا على اهميه المحافظه
على الهدوء في الفتره الراهنه
لا اعتقد ان على الناس الاحتجاج واعتقد ان
الرئيس ترامب اذا تحدثت معه فهو لا يريد
ذلك ايضا لا ينبغي ان نؤذي بعضنا البعض
نريد الهدوء هناك اخر شيء نريده ان يضع
شخص ما ابهام على مقياس العداله لمجرد انه
لا يتفق مع وجهه نظر سياسيه لشخص اخر هذا
هو الخطا وهذا ما يثير غضب الناس وهذا لن
يصمد امام المحكمه سيخبرك المحامي ان هذه
هي اضعف قضيه على الاطلاق
نشره الرابعه مستمره وتتابعون فيها بعد
قليل
المراه السعوديه تستحوذ على اكثر من ثلث
الوظائف في سوق العمل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلنت شركه النفط
الكويتيه حاله الطوارئ بسبب تسرب نفطيه في
غرب البلاد واكد المتحدث الرسمي باسم شركه
نفط الكويت قصي العامر عدم وجود اصابات
ناجمه عن التسرب وعدم التاثر عمليات
الانتاج بالاضافه الى عدم رصد اي غازات
سامه بموقع الحادث ونواه العامر بان الفرق
المعنيه في شركه نفط الكويت تتواجد في
الموقع وتتعامل مع الحادث حسب الاجراءات
المتبعه في الشركه
[موسيقى]
في السعوديه كشفت الهيئه العامه للعقار
للعربيه عن انطلاق عمليات التسجيل العيني
للعقار بالياته المحدثه بدءا من شهر مايو
المقبل وذلك حسب الخطه التشغيليه ومعايير
الجاهزيه في مدينه الرياض وجده والمنطقه
الشرقيه كما افادت المصادر ان هيئه العقار
ستعلن لاحقا عن الاحياء المستفيده التي
ستسجل عقاراتها بشكل تدريجي خلال الفتره
القادمه
ومن الرياض ينضم الينا الرئيس التنفيذي
للهيئه العامه للعقار المهندس عبد الله
الحماد اهلا بك سيد عبد الله الحماد يعني
قبل البدء بتفاصيل عمليات
التسجيل ما هو السجل العقاري يعني خلينا
يعني نعطي
تعريفا مبسطا
حياك الله ارحب فيكم في الساده المشاهدين
السجل العقاري هو وثيقه التملك الجديده
وبالنظام الذي اعتمده مؤخرا النظام
التسجيل العيني للعقار الذي سيحل محل الصك
العقاري خلال المراحل القادمه وفق اجراءات
واعمال التسجيل العين العقاري بحمد الله
اكملت الهيئه العامه للعقار الاستعدادات
والتجهيزات اللازمه لبدء وتفعيل اعمال
السجل العقاري او التسجيل العين العقاري
وفق النظام الذي اعتمده مؤخرا سيد عبد
الله يعني ما الفرق بين توثيق العقارات
بالسجل العقاري وبين توثيقها الحالي بسكوك
الملكيه شو الفرق
توثيق المحدث او ما يسمى بالسجل العقاري
سيتضمن في تفاصيل السجل المعلومات تفصيليه
اكثر سيكون السجل العقاري يحتوي على كافه
البيانات التاريخيه
للعقار او
الاصل العقاري بالاضافه الى دقه البيانات
وموثوقيتها واكتساب الحجيه المطلقه للسجل
العقاري خلال الفتره القادمه بالاضافه الى
ذلك سيكون التعامل مع العقار ونقل ملكيتو
والتعامل في جميع الخدمات التي تختص في
العقار من خلال ما يسمى رقم العقار وهو
اشبه بالرقم الوثيقه للسجل العقاري التي
ستكون باذن الله نقله نوعيه في القطاع
العقاري خلال الفتره القادمه
الاليه المحدثه متى ستدخل حيز التنفيذ
بحول الله تم تحديد ثلاث مدن رئيسيه
مستهدفه لبدء اعمال التسجيل العيني العقار
خلال العام 20 23 وهي مدينه الرياض
ومحافظه جده وضاحيه الدمام نستهدف باذن
الله البدء في اعمال التسجيل العيني
العقار ابتداء من تاريخ 7 مايو في شهر
شوال القادم سيسبق ذلك الاعلان التفصيلي
عن المنطقه المستهدفه للتسجيل باذن الله
في منتصف رمضان تحديدا في تاريخ 6 ابريل
الشهر القادم ليكون لدينا اول المناطق
المستفيده من التسجيل العيني للعقار
وبالتالي على اي اساس سيدنا عبد الله
تختارون المناطق ما المعايير المتبعه لذلك
عده معايير في الحقيقه لعل من اهمها
اكتمال البيانات وتوفرها كذلك درجه تطابق
البيانات وجودتها بالاضافه الى الحاجه
لتفعيل التسجيل العيني للعقار او السجل
العقاري بشكل مباشر بلا شك كما يعرف
الجميع السجل العقاري يعود بفوائد عده
وايجابيات كثيره على ملاك العقارات منها
الموثوقيه ودقه البيانات بالاضافه الى
التحفيز الكبير لجوانب الاستثمار في
المنطقه المعلنه
جوانب التحفيظ للمناطق المعلنه يعني ما
الاليات وكيف يتم التعامل حول هذا الموضوع
طبعا وجود العقارات المسجله عينيه تعطي
العقار فرصه اكبر
واعمال اكبر لتقديم خدمات بجوده اعلى
بالاضافه الى دقه البيانات وموثوقيتها
وتوفرها بصيغه موحده هذه العوامل
بالاضافه الى وجود السجلات التاريخيه تعطي
اضافه للعقارات التي تحمل السجل العقاري
او المحدثه وفق النظام التسجيل على العقار
لتكون اكثر ميزه واكثر فاعليه من العقارات
على الانظمه السابقه نستهدف باذن الله ان
يكون لدينا قطاع عقاري موثوق مسجل بشكل
كامل عن طريق نظام التسجيل العيني للعقار
يكون محفز للاستثمار وكذلك يتوفر فيه
البيانات الدقيقه واللازمه شكرا جزيلا لك
اذا الرئيس التنفيذي للهيئه العامه للعقار
المهندس عبدالله الحمد
منذ بدء موسم الترفيه في السعوديه عام
2019 ارقام لافته حققتها المملكه سواء في
الانشطه والفعاليات او عدد الزائرين نتعرف
على الارقام التي اعلنت عنها الهيئه
العامه للترفيه مع الزميله العنود
نمو متسارع لقطعي الترفيهي والسياحه في
السعوديه هذا ما اعلن عنه رئيس الهيئه
العامه لترفيه تركي علي الشيخ
فقط فالرقم بلغ اكثر من 120 مليون زائر
للفعل ياتي الترفيهيه منذ ان اقيمت عام
2019 ويعتبر هذا العدد مشاهدينا رقما
قياسيا في السعوديه ياتي الارتفاع الملحوظ
في عدد الزائرين في ظل تنوع الفعاليات
التي انجزتها هيئه العامه للترفيه خلال
الاعوام الماضيه فمثلا نظمت الهيئه اول
برنامج مسابقات في العالم يجمع تلاوه
القران والاذان معا وحظيت هذه المسابقه
باقبال عالمي واسع كما اصدرت الهيئه
مشاهدينا اكثر من 11 الف ترخيص لمختلف
الانشطه الترفيهيه والانشطه المسانده اما
عن عدد الفعاليات خلال نفس الفتره فقد
بلغت نحو 9000 فعاليه ما بين انشطه وعروض
ترفيهيه وعروض حيه في المط والمقاهي في
حين تجاوزت ايام الفعاليات سته وسبعين الف
يوم شملت على اكثر من
1381 حفله غنائيه واقيمت مشاهدينا منذ
2019 حتى الربع الاول من العام الحالي
اكثر من 82 مسرحيه عرضت اكثر من 350 مره
وعلى صعيد كره القدم مشاهدينا تمت اقامه
بطوله السوبر كلاسيك او السوبر كلاسيكو
بين البرازيل والارجنتين وكاس مارادونا
بين برشلونه وبوكا جونيورز وكاس موسم
الرياض بين بي اس جي ونجوم الهلال والنصر
اما عن رعايه الهيئه العامه للترفيه
للمسلسلات والبرامج فقامت الهيئه برعايه
العديد من البرامج التلفزيونيه والمسلسلات
ومنها رامز وتاشماطاش وسعودي ايدول
ومسرحيه بودي جارد اضافه الى اقامه اكثر
من 12 امسيه شعريه
[موسيقى]
حضرت وزاره السياحه السعوديه من عدم اصدار
تراخيص للمنشات والاعمال السياحيه ووضعت
الوزاره ضمن نظام السياحه الجديد عقوبات
تشمل غرامه تصل الى مليون ريال وايضا
اغلاق المنشات لممارسي الانشطه السياحيه
للمخالفين الوزاره السعوديه دعت العاملين
في القطاع السياحي الى تعديل الوضع وفق
لوائح نظام السياحه الجديده واصدار
الترخيص قبل نهايه المهله في الخامس
والعشرين من مارس عبر موقع بوابه التراخيص
في موقع الوزاره
[موسيقى]
باتت المراه السعوديه وفق اخر الارقام
تستحوذ على ثلث الوظائف في سوق العمل فقد
كشف تقرير حديث حول تطورات برنامج التحول
الوطني لتمكين فئات المجتمع من دخول سوق
العمل السعودي كشف ان حصه المراه السعوديه
في سوق العمل تتجاوز 34% التقرير كشف ايضا
عن زياده مشاركه الاشخاص ذوي الاعاقه في
سوق العمل السعودي فيما بلغ حجم مبيعات
الاسر المنتجه المدعومه من بنك التنميه
الاجتماعيه حوالي 13 مليار ريال بحسب
التقرير
في الاثناء اطلقت وزاره الموارد البشريه
السعوديه خمس مبادرات نوعيه للمهارات
والتدريب للكوادر الوطنيه كما اعلنت ايضا
عن الحمله الوطنيه للتدريب المبادره تهدف
الى تحفيز القطاع الخاص على التدريب
وتاهيل اكثر من 12% من موظفي القطاع الخاص
السعوديين سنويا بالتالي خفض نسبه البطاله
وكشفت الوزاره ايضا عن وصول عدد وعود
الالتزام بالتدريب الى مليون فرصه تدريبيه
حتى نهايه عام 2025 قدمتها 14 شركه حول
المملكه
وحاول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا في
الاستوديو وكيل وزاره الموارد البشريه
والتنميه الاجتماعيه للمهارات والتدريب
الدكتور احمد الزهراني اهلا بك معنا دكتور
احمد يعني ما شاء الله اطلقتم اليوم خمس
مبادرات للتدريب والتاهيل اخبرنا اكثر عن
هذه المهارات
والجمهور الكريم حقيقه شكرا لاستضافه
واليوم بالنسبه لنا كان الحفل مثابه العرس
اطلقنا فيه مجموعه من مبادرات الهامه لسوق
العمل لماذا اقول ان الحفل كما العرس لانه
كلها مبشرات وكلها اخبار سعيده لسوق العمل
والقطاع الخاص هذه المبادرات اتت لرفع
نسبه مشاركه السعوديين في سوق العمل
وتمكينهم احنا الحمد لله في الوزاره بدانا
ببرامج توطين وزادت مستوى المشاركه في سوق
العمل وصلنا الى 52% واتى دور التمكين
ورفع المهارات ورفع القدرات من خلال
التركيز على الشراكه مع القطاع الخاص فمن
خلال هذه المبادرات اطلقنا مبادره المجالس
القطاعيه المهارات وهي في دورها مبادره
تقوم الشراكه مع القطاع الخاص مؤسسات
القطاع الخاص والمؤسسات ذات العلاقه
بالتخطيط للمهن والمهارات على المستوى
القطاعي والاتفاق على خطه المهارات
والمحفزات ايضا اتت هذه المبادرات بمجموعه
من المحفزات والسياسات والماكنات والقطاع
الخاص سنتحدث عن المحفزات للقطاع الخاص
ولكن من ضمن هذه الحملات وعد لماذا هذا
الاسم بالتحديد وما هي هذه المبادره اصلا
حقيقه الحمله الوطنيه للتدريب وعد هي وعد
من قبل منشات القطاع الخاص بتمكين وتدريب
السعوديين في سوق العمل ورفع مهاراتهم في
سوق العمل هذه الحمله اتت من مبادره من
مجموعه من الشركات في المنشات في القطاع
الخاص بدعم وتنسيق ورفع الجهود من قبل
وزاره الموارد البشريه الحمله الحمدلله
حققت في مرحلتها الاولى تسجيل 14 شركه كما
ذكرتي واليوم تم استلام اتفاقات التدريب
من قبل معالي وزير الموارد والتنميه
الاجتماعيه وصل الرقم الان الى مليون و155
الف فرصه تدريبيه خلال ثلاث سنوات القادمه
ومستمرون ان شاء الله في هذه الحمله
ومستمرون في تحقيق المزيد من الوعود ماذا
عن هذه المبادرات يعني ربما يتساءل شخص هل
هي مدفوعه ام هي تكاليف ربما اضافيه على
القطاع الخاص جميل طبعا من ضمن المبادرات
اللي اطلقناها اطلقنا مبادره اسمها
البرنامج الوطني لتحفيز القطاع الخاص
للتدريب وهو مجموعه من السياسات والمحفزات
للقطاع الخاص على سبيل المثال لدينا مسرعه
المهارات وقسائم التدريب مبادره اطلقت
اليوم وهي تستهدف تدريب 322 الف موظف في
القطاع الخاص وهي مدفوعه بالكامل من قبل
برنامج تنميه القدرات البشريه وهو احد
برامج رؤيه المال من المملكه عشرين ثلاثين
كرساله هامه لاهميه التدريب وان الحكومه
المملكه تستثمر في هذا المجال وتدعو بقيه
الشركات والمنشات الاستثمار طبعا عندنا
المحفزات اخرى غير محفزات الماديه مثل
التمكين مثل انشاء مجتمع التدريب مثل
الافصاح ان التدريب ومؤشرات التدريب هي
مجموعه من محفزات الماليه وغير الماليه
مدى هذه المبادرات من حيث التوقيت هل
تستمر لاشهر او سنوات جميل بعض هذه
المبادرات هي اصلا اتت مبادرات اصلاحيه
سوق العمل ونابع من استراتيجيه سوق العمل
مقرر من قبل مجلس الوزراء مدى الزمني اللي
بمعظم هذه المبادرات ينتهي في عشرين خمسه
وعشرين نتكلم عن ثلاث سنوات قادمه وايضا
نامل على موضوع الاستدامه لهذه المبادرات
واليه الشراكه مع القطاع الخاص مستقبلا
التدريب كم يحفز برايك القطاع الخاص على
التوظيف تحديدا
نعتقد انه التدريب والتوظيف هي وجهان
لعمله واحده لا يمكن ان نقوم بعمليه
التوظيف بدون التدريب ورفع المهارات ولا
يمكن ان يكون هناك تدريب بدون وجود وظيفه
لهذا المتدرب فاحنا نعمل مع الشركات على
اليتين هناك عده وسائل للتدريب في تدريب
موظفيه الموساه هناك تدريب المنتهي
بالتوظيف الخريجين على سبيل المثال ترى
على الوزاره
بالشراكه مع هدف صندوق تنميه الموارد
البشريه برنامج تمهير وهو برنامج للتدريب
على راس العمل ومدفوع بالكامل من قبل
صندوق تنميه الموارد البشريه يعطيكم الف
عافيه شكرا جزيلا لك الدكتور احمد
الزهراني وكيل وزاره الموارد البشريه
والتنميه الاجتماعيه شكرا جزيلا لك
تتابعونا معنا بعد قليل
في يومها العالمي السعوديون الثاني اكثر
الشعوب سعاده
تزامنا مع زياره الرئيس الصيني الى روسيا
الاتحاد الاوروبي يوافق على شراء ذخيره
لاوكرانيا بمليار يورو
في الكويت اعلانه حاله الطوارئ بسبب تسرب
نفطيه غرب البلاد دون ان يتسبب باصابات او
غازات سامه
منذ بدءه عام 2019 موسم الترفيه في
السعوديه يستقبل 120 مليون زائر لنحو 9000
فعاليه
قبل تطبيق النظام الجديد وزاره السياحه
السعوديه تهدد المخالفين بغرامه قدرها
مليون ريال او اغلاق منشات هامه
اهلا بكم من جديد من العاصمه الرياض تحت
في قناه العربيه الليله بمرور 20 عاما على
تاسيسها الذي كان في مارس من العام 2003
وتدشن اليوم اذاعه العربيه اف ام كاول
اذاعه اخباريه في السعوديه الاذاعه تقدم
تغطيه للاخبار السياسيه والاقتصاديه
والرياضيه العربيه والعالميه على مدار
الساعه اضافه الى رصد ومواكبه الاخبار
العاجله محليا وعالميا وتضم الاذاعه شبكه
من المراسلين في كل انحاء العالم
وراء كل خبر قصه تروى تدقيق ورصد بالصوره
شاشه يمتد عمرها لاكثر من عشرين عاما ان
تعرف اكثر مهمه العربيه من عام لاخر الان
جاء دور الصوت والكلمه من العاصمه
السعوديه الرياض ولدت اذاعه العربيه
العربيه اف ام
في
الصوره فاكثر
ومن قلب استديوهات الاخبار بالرياض بضاعه
العربيه تكمل الصوره خبرا لكل المستمعين
حيثما كنتم اسرع من اي وقت مضى اتمنى ان
يصلكم الخبر فور حدوثه واينما كنتم بالصوت
والكلمه سنقدم لك كل ما يهمك ان تعرفه عبر
صباح العربيه اف ام
لطالما كانت الفكره وتفرد المحتوى هما حجر
الزاويه منذ نشاه العربيه تواصل الاذاعه
المشوار بخطه ثابته في بث يمتد عبر الاثير
والوسائط المتعدده الى مستمعيها في العالم
اجمع
عصام عبد السلام اذاعه العربيه اف ام
سانتقل واياكم الى استوديوهات العربيه اف
ام التي انطلقت اليوم صباحا من الرياض
لنتعرف على هويتها وبرامجها
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
العربيه اف ام العربيه اف ام تضاعك في
الصوره لتعرف اكثر
العربيه اف ام على الموجات التاليه
الرياض 103.5
جده 106.6
العربيه اف ام
رنده الشيخ مبروك العربيه اف ام اهلا
وسهلا الله يبارك فيك شكرا لك 3.5 هي موجه
التردد صحيح هويه العربيه اف ام خبرينا
عنا نعم شكرا اول شيء على الاستضافه
نورتينا في الاستوديو اذاعه العربيه اف ام
هي امتداد
لشبكه العربيه الاخباريه هي منصه جديده
تهتم
بنقل الاخبار النوعيه السياسيه الاقتصاديه
الرياضيه كل ما يهمل مستمع
والمتلقي بشكل عام تبث قناه العربيه الان
عم نستمع لبرنامج زميل طاهر بركه الظاهره
السياسيه هل تنقلون كل برامج قناه العربيه
ام انه لديكم برامج اذاعيه حصريه
احنا ننقل ابرز واهم البرامج الموجوده
ولما نقول ابرز يعني كل
قناه العربيه مهمه ولكن نركز على البرامج
التي تحوي الحوار الحوار لانه المستمع في
كثير برامج تبث على قناه العربيه تعتمد
على الجرافيكس والصوره والمستمر والابحار
البصري فهذا شيء يفتقر اليه او تفتقر اليه
الاذاعه
الاداه الوحيده الذي التي ممكن نصل من
خلالها الى المستمع هي الصوت لذلك نركز في
البرامج التي ناخذها او نبثها على شاشه من
شاشه العربيه على الاذاعه انها تكون برامج
حواريه كي يستمع اليها المجتمع بالنسبه
لبرامج الاخرى احنا عندنا مجموعه من
البرامج اللي تنتجها اذاعه العربيه اف ام
برامج
تهتم
بالاقتصاد برامج تهتم بالمعلومات برامج
تثقيفيه تحتوي معلومه على سبيل المثال
عندنا برنامج اسمه العالم في كبسوله يتنقل
بالمستمع في انحاء العالم ومن كل بلد ياخذ
معلومه غريبه عندنا برنامج اسمه ما وراء
الحدث اخباري يركز على تحليل الاخبار وما
وراءها من تداعيات
الحدث هذا البرنامج
نتناول فيه حدث معين بارز على الساحه
السياسيه ونناقش في المحللين والمختصين في
تداعيات هذا الحدث واهميته وتاثيره على
المتلقي او المواطن العربي والعالم
فقط بالرياض ام بكافه
مناطق اليوم
ايضا جميل احنا كما انطلاق اليوم انطلقنا
فيها من الرياض من العاصمه السعوديه
الرياض كبدايه في المرحله الاولى حنبدا من
الرياض نتوسع ننتقل الى جده ثم الدمام ثم
من داخل السعوديه الى خارجها في الوطن
العربي
يعني اقتربنا عده ايام تفصلنا عن شهر
رمضان المبارك هل لديكم برامج خاصه بشهر
الكريم لدينا عده برامج جهزنا
هيكل كامل لبرنامج لبرامج رمضان طبعا
برامج رمضان هي مختلفه قليلا عن البرامج
العاديه
فيها تركيز على الصحه على الصيام على
المعلومات الدينيه على الشخصيات الثقافيه
التاريخيه
عندنا برامج طيب ماذا عن التفاعل مع المجت
معيه الاذاعه بالنسبه لالنا هي تفاعل مع
المتصلين مع الان الماسجز او التواصل
العربيه فانت تتواصل مع المستمعين في
مرحلتها الاولى عبر منصات التواصل
الاجتماعي تويتر فيسبوك انستجرام ممكن
يتابعونا ممكن يسمعونا على اليوتيوب على
البث المباشر وطبعا عبر السيارات كل الناس
اللي في الرياض يقدروا يسمعونا في الطريق
طيب خلينا نتحدث عن وجودكم على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي والتطبيقات الذكيه نعم
زي ما قلنا مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي كلها
احنا موجودين فيها على منصاتنا منصات
العربيه المختلفه اليوتيوب كمان عندنا
تطبيق العربيه ممكن يشاهدوا فيه من خلال
تطبيق الشاشه وقناه الحدث ايضا واذاعه
العربيه فاحنا موجودين في كل مكان اين
مكان اذا شكرا جزيلا لك رنده مجاهدينا
يعني
قناه العربيه واستمعوا الى العربيه اف ام
شكرا شكرا
[موسيقى]
في 150 جريمه احتيال مالي على مستوى
السعوديه وذلك في مجال التقنيه والبرمجيات
واستقبال اجهزه الكترونيه تتعلق بتفعيل
الشرائح الاتصال وتمرير المكالمات
استعدادا لشهر رمضان المبارك اعلن الرئيس
العام لشؤون المسجد الحرام والمسجد النبوي
عبد الرحمن السديس عن جاهزيه الحرمين
لاستقبال الاعداد المليونيه خلال رمضان
وتجهيز كافه المواقع للمعتمرين والمصلين
مؤكدا ان الحاله التشغيليه لجميع المرافق
في جاهزيه تامه بموازاه ذلك يباشر 1600
كادر تنفيذ الخطه التشغيليه لهيئه الهلال
الاحمر السعودي بمنطقه المدينه المنوره
لشهر رمضان عبر 39 مركزا اسعافيا تتوزع في
ارجاء المنطقه المراكز تشمل اكثر من 62
فرقه اسعافيه مدعمه باحدث التجهيزات
الاليه
وستكثف الفرق خدماتها في المسجد يوميا
خصوصا خلال صلاه التراويح والتهجد
في جده اطلقت هيئه فنون الطهيفه عاليات
سوق رمضان لاستعراض الطهي المحلي
والمنتجات الرمضانيه بالاضافه الى تقديم
تجربه اثرائيه عن الماضي وما يتبعها من
عادات اجتماعيه ارتبطت بالمائده الرمضانيه
السعوديه هيئه فنون الطريق قدمت ايضا
محاكاه مختزله ومكثفه عن اجواء رمضان في
35 ركنا يتضمنهم معرض سوق رمضان تتنوع بين
تقديم المخبوزات والحلويات والتمور
والبهارات
اعلنت الهيئه السعوديه للفضاء عن الابحاث
العلميه التي سيجريها رواد الفضاء
السعوديين في الربع الثاني من العام
الجاري ضمن طاقم المهمه الفضائيه في محطه
الفضاء الدوليه
المهمه السعوديه في الفضاء تتضمن اجراء 11
تجربه بحثيه علميه ستعزز نتاجها من مكانه
السعوديه عالميا كما تستهدف تلك الابحاث
ايضا مجالات الابحاث البشريه وعلوم
الخلايا بالاضافه الى الامطار الصناعيه او
الامطار الصناعي فعليا
نعود الى فعاليات سوق رمضان وينضم الينا
من سوق رمضان في جده التاريخيه مراسل
العربيه سعود الخلف اهلا بك يا سعود يعني
اقترب رمضان واقتربت معه الاجواء الجميله
اخبرنا عن التحضيرات في السوق حيث تتواجد
بالفعل وكل عام والجميع بالف خير بمناسبه
قرب دخول شهور شهر رمضان المبارك احنا
موجودين اليوم في هذه الفعاليه فعاليه سوق
رمضان ولتقوم عليها هيئه فنون الطهي واللي
تعتبر واحده من الهيئات التابعه لوزاره
الثقافه واللي بتاخذنا الى اجواء رمضان
طبعا هذه الفعاليه تختص بكل ما له علاقه
بالثقافه الرمضانيه في السعوديه من
ملبوسات كما تشاهدون الان وايضا من
المنتجات الخاصه برمضان او المنتجات التي
تزين سفره رمضان من
ادوات يعني تجمل السفره وايضا من
الماكولات وكل ما له علاقه بشهر رمضان كما
تشاهدون
الفعاليه معموله في
اركان او بوتات يعني تنقلنا الى الثقافه
في منطقه مكه المكرمه من مكه والمدينه
وايضا
الطائف وجده بتصاميمها التي توحي بهذه
الثقافه في منطقه الحجاز وتوجد في داخلها
بالورد والدهن نعم ونحن نشاهد معك هذه
الصور يعني لدينا يعني قليل من الوقت تفضل
وهذه بعض الصور يعني كان الهدف ايضا نقل
الزائر الى الثقافه الرمضانيه سابقا طبعا
في كل رمضان تختلف مساله تزيين البيوت
واستعداداتها عن العام الذي يسبق في هذا
المكان
حاولوا بشكل او باخر نقل الثقافه القديمه
ودمجها بالثقافه الجديده في هذا المهرجان
او هذه الفعاليه شكرا جزيلا لك سعود الخلف
من جده التاريخيه وسوق رمضان
نتابع مشاهدينا هذه الصور التي وصلتنا قبل
قليل من موسكو للقاء الذي جمع الرئيسين
الصيني والروسي طبعا الرئيس الصيني تشيم
بينجا هو بزياره رسميه الى موسكو تستمر
ليومين كان
المتحدث باسم الكرملين ديمتري سكوف اعلن
انه الزعيمين سيتطرقان الى عده ملفات من
اهمها المبادره
الصينيه للسلام بشان اوكرانيا نذكر بانه
بانه الصين حاولت ان تكون جهه سلام وتلعب
دور الوسيط في هذا النزاع حيث نشرت بشهر
فبراير شباط وثيقه من اثنتي عشره نقطه
تدعو فيها الطرفين موسكو وكاف الى وقف
الاعمال العدائيه حسب وصفها والى اجراء
مباحثات سلام حينها لم تلقى هذه المبادره
الصينيه ترحيبا غربيا طبعا مسائل تطوير
العلاقات الثنائيه بين الطرفين والوضع
العالمي الراهن هو من ابرز المواضيع التي
ستضع على ملف الطاوله نستمع
طبعا نستمع قليلا الى
هذا
الاجتماع من جهتها طبعا الخارجيه
الاوكرانيه استغلت هذه الزياره ودعت
الرئيس الصيني لاستغلال نفوذه مع الجانب
الروسي والضغط على فلاديمير بوتين لوقف
هذه العمليه العسكريه كما تسميها موسكو
والانسحاب من الاراضي المحتله كما وصفتها
نستمع الصين في الاعوام القادمه ستقوم
بخطوه قادمه في تنميتها وستحقق تلك
الاهداف من دون الشركه التي تضعونها نصبه
اعينكم
رمزيا بشده اننا قد التقينا
[موسيقى]
كرئيس الصيني الشعبيه
خلال الوقت القليل المنصرم
قمنا بخطوات كبيره في تنميه علاقتنا
اكثر من مرتين التجاري
[موسيقى]
185 مليار دولار
من المهام المشتركه والاهداف
[موسيقى]
انكم شخصيا والاصدقاء الصينيون ايضا
الصينيه
موقعا فيما يتعلق بالمسائل الدوليه
الاوكرانيه
[موسيقى]
تنطلق اليوم الدوره العاشره من مهرجان عفت
السينمائي تحت شعار بحر من الافلام يتضمن
المهرجان عرض افلام طالبات وخريجات مدرسه
الفنون السينمائيه بالاضافه الى مجموعه
مختاره من افلام الطلاب الدوليين كما سيصل
عدد الافلام المقدمه الى اكثر من 2000
فيلم من اكثر من 100 دوله حيث تم تقليص
العدد واختيار 46 فيلما من 27 دوله ليتم
عرضها على جمهوري هذا المهرجان
يصادف اليوم العشرين من مارس اليوم
العالمي للسعاده الذي اعتمدته الامم
المتحده السنويا مؤشر السعاده العالمي
لعام 2023 وفقا لنتائج استطلاع شركه ابسوس
للابحاث اشاره الى ان الشعب السعودي احتل
المرتبه الثانيه في قائمه اكثر الشعوب
سعاده في العالم بعد الصين بنسبه 86% مؤشر
قياس السعاده العالميه يعتمد على 30 جانبا
من جوانب الحياه منها الحياه الاجتماعيه
ظروف المعيشه والصحه العقليه والرفاهيه
ختام الرابعه مع العناوين
تزامنا مع زياره الرئيس الصيني الى روسيا
الاتحاد الاوروبي وافق على شراء ذخيره
لاوكرانيا بمليار يورو
في الكويت اعلان حالات الطوارئ بسبب تسرب
نفطي غرب البلاد دون ان يتسبب باصابات او
غازات سامه
منذ بدئه عام 2019 موسم الترفيه في
السعوديه يستقبل 120 مليون زائر لنحو 9000
فعاليه
قبل تطبيق النظام الجديد وزاره السياحه
السعوديه تهدد المخالفين بغرامه قدرها
مليون ريال او اغلاق منشاتهم
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]